when the presidency of the european
council
for the semester asked me to be their
ambassador
i was
i was impressed by the choice i was
surprised and very much humbled
uh by their thinking that an astronaut
would be a good ambassador
at the same time it made sense to me
because
europe is future
it's to me
it's one and the same word the future is
the evolution of society the the
evolution of our country is evolving
into something else something bigger
something better
but space also talks about future
it is the
the place where future things happen and
are prepared so
the experience has been amazing i i've
had a privileged platform to talk to
people to tell them how important it is
to believe in europe to feel
the need to be european
not because you lose your
your national identity but because
through your national identity you can
bring your
your part of support to improve what
europe is today it doesn't matter
whether i'm italian or french or german
europe europe is our country i can cross
those boundaries that we designed
through millennia of wars and and
of a history that we that we need to
overcome
because one thing that my experience in
space taught me is that those lines
those borders on the ground
are imaginary they don't exist they are
invisible from space
because they are really inside us so our
part as citizen is really to
to try and
come out of those limits that are within
us to understand that they exist and to
destroy them so that we can all be
better
stronger when we are united i believe
that uh in in the in the six months of
the semester
from this privileged platform i've had
the chance to talk about my experience
as an italian that through europe
because i'm an i'm an italian astronaut
of the european space agency i it's been
a journey that started as a
uh that started from italy from sicily
actually where i'm from crossed across
italy and through europe
realized
i realized my dream and it would not
have been possible without the european
the the european astronaut corp european
space agency and the roles of all the
countries involved with space
uh i would like to say even more i am
even more than european i believe that
that the future should be of a global
understanding that we are all humans
traveling in one spacecraft we call it
planet earth but we are traveling to
space in the one planet that we know
supports life so we need to be together
understanding that this is our only home
and that we need to
treat it really well and be
understanding uh in order to continue in
our future the experience of being in
orbit for six months is so unique in a
way and
the environment is so unique that my
idea was that if there was something i
could do on the ground then i wouldn't
do it while i was up there and it was a
conscious effort not to not to miss it
instead i tried to do things that were
not possible anywhere else the space
station is very big it's a it's an
amazing environment and i didn't miss
any of the small things
you can really do without the small
things when you have so much more when
you are in orbit every time i tell my
story every time i relieve my story it's
almost as if i'm doing it all over again
and i'm and also i i'm letting people
take part in it being an active
participant in my experience so when i
was in orbit i i was communicating to
the ground through blogs through the
social network social media and out of
that experience came the book bolade
that i wrote bolare means flying and
it's also a very famous italian song but
it's something everybody can identify
with both in italy and outside of italy
so the book is a collection of the
stories that i that i brought while i
was in space so
really it's it's the first book that was
written in space one more thing that is
very important for me it's also a way to
give back all my proceedings will go
into a scholarship to let other people
experience what i did because when i was
16 i won a scholarship and
i went to the united states for one year
and that changed my life so maybe if i
can change one person's life i would
have done my my part two what does an
astronaut do when you're on the ground
after flight well uh it would be very
frustrating for astronauts to be happy
or to be working only when they are in
space in reality 90 of our work is done
on the ground so right now i'm i'm much
busier than i was before during training
and while in orbit because i i work in
all different kinds of environment as
far as a new space flight i i'm hop of
naturally hoping for a new flight i've
been dreaming about it since i came back
because once you once you once you have
a taste of what it's like to live in
space
it
it becomes something that you want to
try again we don't know nowadays what it
will take for the next generation of
astronauts to become astronauts
in my generation we selected or
the european space agency selected
pilots and mostly test pilots engineers
and scientists
but in the future we will need doctors
we will need
operators we will need people of all
kinds to to be more than explorers to be
colonizers
because there is no way of knowing what
uh what we need in the future my
suggestion to the next generation is to
be good at what they love to do
um the best thing that you can do in
order to aspire to something is to be
the best at what you do and then that's
how you that that's how people notice
you science is the core business of what
we do on the space station which is
a
a laboratory is the biggest orbital lab
ever built by by humans and that's what
we do 60 hours a week of incredible
science that cannot be performed
anywhere else in the world and that's
why we are out the world
technology is also part of what we do
today on the space station we are
testing the technology that will allow
us to
go further into into space 10 years from
now 20 years from now when the new
generation of astronauts will step on
the surface of an asteroid or maybe back
to the moon or to mars they will use the
technology that we are developing today
is there a role for us as astronauts yes
our role is what i'm doing right now is
to talk to people inspire them with our
stories and show them that there is a
future for technology science
mathematics engineering all these things
improve society make it a better place
to live give us inspiration give us
purpose and make let us evolve into the
future generations of explorers